you're watching swipe coming up on this
week's show top of the blocks meet a
Minecraft megastar I find out what it
takes to trick your brain into believing
or feeling something that isn't fair and
hold the phone why Samsung's had such a
bad week
welcome to swipe even if you're not a
gamer chances are you've heard of
Minecraft the building block game has
become one of the most popular titles in
the world even spawning its own
celebrity subculture dantdm s YouTube
channel which features videos of him
playing it has been viewed more than
eight billion times and Chris got to
meet him for a chat yeah welcome back
into minecraft went to Dan Middleton or
dantdm as he's known to his fans is a
YouTube superstar dantdm evolves into
okay this worked a little bit better
last time let's pick the big old British
gamer has over 15 million subscribers
look at those guys happy little
creatures at one point last year his
main channel was the most popular in the
world I got into online video a long
time ago before YouTube was even a thing
there was sites to produce like flash
animation stop-motion animations I kind
of got into that and started making my
own and then YouTube came along and it
was kind of the only place you could you
could view let people view your content
without literally sitting them in front
of your screen so I started building
like silly little animations then got
even more into gaming then gaming on
YouTube kind of blew up and has gone
from zero to 100 very very quickly
Dan's videos mainly feature him playing
and commentating on minecraft but did he
ever expect to build a career out of the
creative construction games as a massive
surprise huge surprise when it started
going crazy because when I started doing
minecraft videos there was kind of an
established set of creators that kind of
made their name of Minecraft already so
I was quite
saturated space so it was quite it was
quite cool to have like fine to find a
new niche and it just take off oh jeez
the meteor true the game has sold over a
hundred million copies worldwide gives
my watch out oh my goodness most of its
players are young children with Dan's
main audience being eight to ten year
olds he says he specializes in
storytelling I would say my video is
going to stick out because of these
story elements something that really
connected especially in the Minecraft
videos is I created my own characters to
support kind of a tutorial aspect of the
videos and then the the stories and the
characters pretty much took over where
they literally have their own adventures
in their own world Dan's got over 8
billion YouTube views and makes money
through online ads he wouldn't tell me
how much he earns but he's well aware of
the business opportunities he's even got
a book out yeah I think there's a lot of
potential especially when you've built
big characters like dr. trailers for
example and my main character Dan Tem
who essentially me but kind of my
computer-generated counterpart there's a
lot of potential for merchandise and
other stories because or fans kind of
really do connect with those characters
so I have like a little plushies of my
character which people really enjoy yeah
it's not all about making money there
have been some unexpected benefits as
well yeah I've had a lot of support from
parents specifically about helping their
children with ADHD and autism with my
videos using it as kind of something
that they can focus on when they're
feeling a little bit unstable or having
a bad day they can really use my videos
to focus on something to distract them
from everything else we all know what
the internet is like when it comes to
online trolls and someone as popular as
you must get their fair share of
negative comments how do you deal with
those I do get them every day all the
time the easiest thing to do is
literally ignore them as soon as you
give them any kind of attention
whatsoever then that's where they're
after pretty much they want to get you
annoys they want to get some kind of
argument going so you literally just
ignore them and they'll get bored this
here at the moment Dan's taking his
online persona to the live stage in his
first ever tour unsurprisingly it's
already sold out
Chris Creegan Sky News stay with us
still to come are we getting
touchy-feely with a special kind of
glove that's coming right up after a
roundup of this week's tech news
Samsung has ended production of its new
Galaxy Note 7 smartphone 2.5 million
devices were recalled after dozens
caught fire or exploded last month but
this was followed by reports of
replacement phones doing the same thing
the company is now giving customers fire
resistant packages so they can send back
their faulty handsets Sony's PlayStation
VR launched in the UK this week the
virtual reality kit works with existing
ps4 consoles
it's the third major headset launched
this year following Facebook's oculus
rift and the HTC vive Sony's hoping to
compete with a device that's cheaper
than its rivals driverless cars are
being trialed in Milton Keynes the UK
built vehicles use cameras and detection
technology to navigate but they can only
reach speeds of up to 15 miles per hour
and internet trolls who create
derogatory hashtags or post humiliating
photoshopped pictures could face jail
under new rules the Crown Prosecution
Service has published guidance to help
police decide when to press charges
one in four teenagers suffers abuse
online coming up in a moment we take to
the battlefield in our games review but
first
haptic technology is a kind of feedback
that can mimic physical touch developers
have been experimenting with it to try
and make virtual reality gaming even
more immersive and to potentially help
people recovering from brain injuries I
invited one CEO with his prototype
haptic glove into Sky for demonstration
those sensors being strapped to my
fingertips are about to make it possible
for me to feel things that aren't really
there oh yeah yep cold cold yes Carl was
like cold water yeah oh la Heat and then
we can put the heat through it as well
oh that's my son
that's like oh yeah these will be good
in winter by way of whatever sensation
Nigel selects on the screen I should
feel with my hand if we put in a hot mug
yeah you should feel a pressure and the
pressure is created by simply there's a
small bladder
just on the behind the fingertips and we
just inflate that bladder Nigel's been
working with the University of
Southampton to develop the haptic device
it was initially designed for people
who've had a stroke or brain injury why
don't understand is how is this helping
rehabilitate a stroke patient so you
will mimic the sensation of picking up a
cup of tea or you'll mimic the sensation
of moving something and that will find a
new pathway of nerves in your neural
pathway from your hand and fingers to
your brain because you're carrying out
action because you're carrying out
action seeing it on a screen seeing that
you're actually doing it the haptics
trend is gaining popularity particularly
in gaming as even such a thing as a
haptic suit designed to let your whole
body feel sensations of the video game
you're playing
so that's anything from being hit by a
bullet to weather changes nigel also
wants to expand into gaming as his team
progresses with the project we can mimic
a touch of sandpaper it feels like my
fingers vibrating so how we do this is
you adjust the frequencies of the
vibration but what about the cost
for the rehabilitation market be selling
it for under 500 pounds okay a gaming
market well in theory similar around
that sort of market which you think is
presumably the price will come down the
more than you sell yes the more we sell
the more yes the more we get the more we
can produce it's a bit sensitive at the
moment and hopefully it's working as
with all prototypes there are still a
few kinks to iron out time for this
week's games review now where Luke has
been fighting for us the latest
installment in the Battlefield series is
out and battlefield one is doing
something a little bit different and
then its competitors like Call of Duty
you and titanfall all those games are
moving forward and forward and further
into the future battlefield one is
taking it back to world war 1 which is
actually quite refreshing change if you
play a lot of these type of games with
battlefield 1 going all the way back to
World War 1 they are introducing
something called war stories so what
rather than following just one character
all the way through who changes the
course of the war actually looks at a
series of individual soldiers and
follows their stories and quite often
end in death and it works it's a very
you know touching subject matter war
which should be but will will one I
think in particular within the amount of
lives lost so yes if you are not a big
fan of shooters or you just bit bored of
the way they're going have a look at
at first glance Dragon Quest builders
looks like it might be a ripoff of
Minecraft but it isn't it's actually a
really unique take on the genre
whereas minecraft has been viewed as
more of a social experience where you're
making things to share with friends
Dragon Quest builders is a sandbox
action RPG there is more of a solo
adventure so you can play it on your own
your aim is to wander around this world
there's limited combat with these
skeletons that come out at night but
your aim is to collect resources and
basically channel them into rebuilding a
village and looking after the villages
that move back in there it's an exciting
game and one that if you don't quite
click with Minecraft all of your kids
are looking for something new it's
definitely worth having a look at
Civilization six is the latest
installment in the long-running
civilization franchise and it's a grand
strategy turn-based game so your aim is
to take amination
from its early days in the Stone Age and
go with it all the way through to the
space race and you're basically
competing against other civilizations
and you know having to interact with
them trade with them be diplomatic with
them or if you feel like it you can just
conquer them that's the beauty of Civ
there's no right way to play if you
played civilization before there's a lot
to love about this installment and if
you haven't this really does seem like
one of the best times to get involved
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can watch any of our swipe episodes
in our YouTube playlist just type in the
sky and you swipe now stay up to date
with all the latest tech stories
throughout the week on sky news on
mobile tablet catch up sky cute and
snapchat we'll be back next week hope
you can join us then bye-bye